what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are going to kind of cheat a
little bit and we're gonna sort of
bypass the first story arcs of Superman
and actually comics by Brian Michael
Bendis and I know a lot of you guys are
just kind of like no but hear me out
first I can hear me up
so what Bendis basically did with
actually comics vol 1 and in Superman
vol 1 is essentially the same thing he
did with New Avengers vol 1 but spread
over two different comics so the little
guys who were not familiar with Brian
Michael Bendis business has been a part
of the comic book industry for a long
long time I probably running up on 18
years now and even before that if you
count Indy publications and the idea
behind this was that were business did
things like ultimate universes so on and
so forth and Marvel in the early to
mid-2000s they basically cancelled
Avengers and then relaunched it as new
Avengers and so what bidness did in the
first story art which was called
breakout was basically established the
New Avengers rightly basically tell us
like what the new roster was gonna be
who was gonna be part of it and why they
were gonna be part of it so you got like
spider-man you got Luke Cage I think it
was you got like Wolverine Iron Man
Captain America so on so forth and it
was kind of just laying the groundwork
for it for the new team that's basically
what he did with action and Superman
Action Comics was just kind of a
six-issue glorified arc of business just
being like hey this is my Superman book
now and he did that by basically
introducing rogles R and saying like
he's the reason why Krypton was
originally destroyed for some people it
was a cool story or for others it was
unnecessary but regardless of the
circumstance up with Superman vol 1 all
that did was basically come off the
heels of Action Comics and have like the
earth thrown into the Phantom Zone so we
can cover those in a future point in
time if you want but they're not really
necessary not by any standard of
measurement really to understand this
all you have to know is that mr. oz the
father of Superman basically came back
and then told Jonathan Kent like I want
to take you on a tour of the galaxy in
order to help you better understand your
powers and your place on the greater
picture so that you can become a more
effective superhero and then Lois Lane
went along with him that's basically it
like that that's really all that
happened that pertains to this
everything else is kind of unnecessary
fluff but again I kind of leave it to
you guys you guys may want to see you
guys may not want to see it's really
your call I wasn't the biggest fan of it
but again it is Brian Michael Bendis and
so it may all come to kind of curl right
back around later on we don't really
know but the idea behind this is that
again this basically picks up with the
idea that Jonathan Kent is a
into a teenager now the cool thing about
this is that we don't know exactly how
this happened I mean we all kind of
given an explanation
you know insofar as Jonathan Kent says
we basically ended up orbiting a black
hole so time travel faster for me than I
did for you and so I essentially just
aged up now we may get like a more
in-depth explanation later on but all
this part really does the the return of
super super super boy has really just
explained what he's been doing at the
ton you know between the time that he
originally left Superman and the time
that he showed up here now kind of a
cool moment that really came out of that
was the conversation that took place
between jor-el and Superman himself when
jor-el basically says you're really
nothing more than a stopgap measure that
Superman's just a guy who's there in in
like fights and bad guys and
occasionally Darkseid and like that's it
he's basically you know getting cats out
of trees and stopping robberies and not
doing anything that really makes
humanity better and it was kind of cool
it was actually a really really cool
introspective look at the character of
Superman but again with Jonathan Kent's
showing back up here it's almost one of
these things where there's more
questions and answers because it's kind
of like okay what's going on and it's
kind of funny because initially like
Superman doesn't actually believe it's
his son because it's like well as far as
Superman's concern Jonathan's only been
gone for three weeks but from Jonathan's
perspective he's been gone for years and
so it's kind of cool because of course
he grabs his son he's up racing back
home to Lois Lane because of course
she's since returned by this point in
time and then she's kind of freaking out
like a mom does right like oh my god my
baby
my baby's back kind of it's kind of a
funny thing to see and this is where war
bindus really shines as a writer when
he's going hard to the paint and like
riding one heck of a story oh he's he's
almost second to none and he captures
human emotion like incredibly well but
like kind of seemed like Lois Lane
freaking you know freaking out about her
son you know and and and so on and so
forth and almost kind of like blaming
jor-el for like why it is a super boy
aged up what he does is kind of say okay
look let's go ahead and have the
conversation about what it is it's been
happening this entire time and it's cool
because when they were brought onto the
ship of jor-el what he basically said is
look you guys kind of have your own
quarters here unlike this giant Space
Station more or less that we're staying
on and you guys can customize and you
guys can make them your own and it's
kind of cool because at this point it's
really Jonathan Kent outside the purview
of his father and this is very important
here and the reason why is because for
Jonathan Kent as a character where
Superman's taught him a lot of the very
important lessons you know the idea that
just because you can do something
doesn't mean you should but if you have
the ability to fix something you
the responsibility to fix something
because he passed a lot of those very
important lessons on to his son it did
help Jonathan to grow as is kind of a
young man coming into his own but at the
end of the day he was under the shadow
of his father and he was also kind of
chasing this idea of wanting to become a
member of the Teen Titans but with all
that basically out of the picture
because Jonathan wanted to go with his
grandfather because he wasn't allowed to
be on the Teen Titans because he's kind
of outside of that now it's one of these
things were like the galaxy is his
oyster he's bound by nothing and is
Jonathan kind of coming to terms with
that and saying like well now just a
clean slate are the ideas for me to go
out into the galaxy to kind of gain a
better understanding of myself and
that's what we're gonna do and his
grandfather takes them on a litany of
adventures by basically saying your
father has been fighting on earth really
just kind of being being a piece of
bubblegum in a wall stopping what's what
appears to be a leak which is in reality
a giant flood and he doesn't really know
what's actually going on what you need
to understand is that you have a much
larger role to play in the galaxy and
even the universe itself then your
father does you can be better than what
your father is your father is not living
up to his true potential as it was kind
of one of these things are saying like
Jonathan you can be greater than your
father you just have to get some
perspective and so what he does is
literally take him out have them face
off against the dominators different
things like that and then of course Lois
Lane puts on a suit designed to kind of
allow her body to adapt to like the deep
space environment dudes like the riggers
that space can have on the normal human
form but of course
Jonathan's also taken to this
intergalactic trade place where like
there's some shady people it's almost
like moss eisely but it's kind of cool
because what it does is it shows like
the bigger picture of Superman right so
like when they land on this planet
because of the fact that that Lois is
wearing the crest of El wearing like the
house crest of the house of El when she
shows up here people start paying her
special attention and where she
initially starts to think of oh hey well
you know it's kind of basica than done
the nature of Superman the response to
jor-el is no they see you as like a
savior somebody who's basically wanted
to like make their lives better and so
what this is designed to do is really
kind of point to the notion that the
legacy of Superman and really his
reputation precedes him and the sense it
is not just Superman and the actions
he's committed on earth if Superman and
the fact that his reputation extends
into the galaxy itself yet again hitting
on the notion that Superman's not living
up to his full potential and so again
it's kind of interesting because when
you look at his character and you look
at like what Jonathan Kent's learning
here it's kind of a much bigger expanse
of the idea the Superman can't be
everywhere
once but the reality of the situation is
a Superman can fly to other planets
Superman can can travel through space to
other parts of the of the galaxy and
even other parts of the universe and so
the question is if Superman is only
fighting on earth then it's almost like
Superman is just saving you know saving
people in like one neighborhood on the
entirety of earth it's really kind of
that perspective he's saving people only
on one planet in a infinitely expanding
universe full of like a potentially
infinite number of planets and so it's
like he's not really doing much in the
greater the greater span of things and
again that's where jor-el is hitting
home to Jonathan Kent now the cool thing
about this is when Jonathan meets Lobo
for the first time and it's kind of
awesome because when when when Lobo
meets him he's just kind of like yeah so
like you're like the super kid and like
right off the bat Jonathan's kind of
like no you can call me Superboy and
this is cool this is one of the coolest
interactions because what this does is
it shows how emboldened Superboy's
become and what it means is that his
confidence is increasing because what
Bendis is doing is building the
character of Superboy off of like the
super sons and if you go back and you
read the super sons away was written
Superboy lacked confidence he didn't
really believe in himself in a way that
he should have he understood his powers
or at least as they existed at the time
and he knew what he wanted to achieve
but there's a difference between having
a goal and having the confidence to
shoot for that goal and so where he was
really young he was unsure of himself
what this is showing is that in these
various skirmishes that are happening
both off on panel and off panel he's
becoming a lot more confident and a lot
more assertive especially when you're
talking about speaking up to somebody
like Lobo who can easily go toe-to-toe
with Superman if not defeat him
depending on who's writing the story at
the time it was kind of this cool thing
because when Lobo starts talking to him
he basically says look like maybe you
don't know this kid you're not a man
when someone tells you you are you're a
man when you decide now this is
incredibly important it's astronomically
important because one of the things that
we kind of deal with for a lot of you
guys who are young it's almost kind of
like this coming-of-age thing right like
you will cross a line and like the world
will recognize you as an adult right
like they'll recognize you as being like
an adult you know on earth like that
number is basically eighteen or
twenty-one depending on on how you want
to look at it you're you and you can
fight in the military at 18 but you
really can drink alcohol in the States
until you're 21 so depending on how you
want to look at it what's really being
told to us here is that outside the
planet Earth outside this small little
mud ball in like this huge giant
universe there's
no rules out there it's no-man's land
you do what you can to get what you can
and you're literally just making your
way in the universe and so because of
the fact that Superboy is in a world
where there are no rules you become a
man when you say you're a man when
you're old enough to stick up for your
own when you're old enough to basically
protect you and your own and so it's
kind of cool here because that's what
Lobo is basically saying like yes you
look like a kid but if you're old enough
to do your own if you're old enough to
make your way in the universe then
you're a man you're a man when you
decide that you want to be when you want
to stop being a child and stop viewing
things as a child and acting like a
child
this is very important this is very very
huge because of course what we also end
up finding out here is that there's
basically kind of like this slave trade
going on now it's not a great big huge
focal point of the story but it's a
focal point insofar as Superboy shows up
and literature starts like attacking
these slave traders and just kind of
destroy them wiping them out everywhere
he can to feeding them and so on and so
forth this is a very important thing
because we're Louis ends up traveling
back to earth and basically leaving
Superboy with us with his grandfather
Superboy begins to sort of look at
jor-el and seen jor-el for the kind of
lessons he's imposing on Jonathan Kent
and this is something that I hope you're
noticing here that what URL is really
imposing on Jonathan Kent is do what it
takes and forget morality that you do
whatever it takes to win and it really
kind of fires directly against what
Superman's been teaching a son the
entire time and this is important
because what this means is that if
Superboy were to adopt this philosophy
and say I will do whatever I need to do
in order to achieve my goal then you
really become nothing better than the
people that you're fighting against
right like there's no differentiation
between the good guys and the bad guys
if you adopt that philosophy if you
adopt that ideology what differentiates
the good guys and the bad guys is a good
guys basically have a kind of moral code
and saying like I will do what I need to
do in order to win this fight so long as
I don't cross this line I've created for
myself that is one of these things where
Jonathan's beginning to learn that his
grandfather is essentially insane and
that's exactly what he tells to Tran and
Louis
jor-el is crazy and we have to find a
way to stop this guy so again it's cool
here and it's really really intriguing
because again a lot of the stuff that
sort of went on we don't really know
like we don't really know what other
things happened in the life of Superboy
and jor-el
that let him kind of down this path to
believing and that his grandfather's
basically insane and that's what we're
kind of waiting on Bendis to explain to
us but with that being said guys we're
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end if you are new here to come this
explain make sure you guys are the sub
button to become part of the rod core if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like
and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]